vaccination the world is not ready for
what happened inside the bubble
drama this soon is a little bit crazy it
is unlike anything
we have ever seen on this show before i
i truly think we
have outdone ourselves this time not
done yet you are done get out of here
it definitely goes up on the mount
rushmore of
wild seasons of bachelor bachelorette
and what exactly takes it there
i will just say it is unbelievably
unexpected
and for those that think that they know
exactly how this plays out
you don't we need clarity as you guys
have been saying
tuesday october 13th pounding you want
clarity i'm so falling in love with you
you tell claire crawley she blew up the
bachelorette
congratulations you've just blown up the
bachelorette what's going through your
mind
what's happening for you to say someone
blew up your show
i love claire to death love these guys
but claire took us on
a journey the likes of which we have
never seen and it
to the point where i said
congratulations you just blew up the
bachelorette
um this will be a roller coaster ride
unlike any other and the great thing
about the show now
and even going into quarantine and i'm
glad we've embraced changed the way we
have the last
several years and made the show more
organic because it allows us to to give
a season like you're about to watch
which is embrace it the good the bad the
ugly warts and all
you're gonna see it it sounds like this
was the bachelorette
in a pressure cooker with no release it
definitely was a pressure cooker in that
you didn't get away from it um myself
producers
the cast the crew it made things very
intense
it wasn't good or bad it was just
different and it was very intense
myself included i was there 24 7
on top of this show i i probably know
this cast
more intimately than any group i've ever
known just because i was with them
every single day i was neighbors with
some of them while we were quarantined
trying to get into the bubble so
i got to know these guys unlike any
group i've probably
ever met before on this show talk a
little bit about
the specifics of what filming was like
and how different it was this time did
you guys have hometowns did you do
a typical night one in this other resort
yeah so obviously uh everybody knows
that we quarantined out
in uh the laquinta resort out in palm
springs um
how things play out i'll let you find
out some of those things like
hometowns and the fantasy suites and all
that how we made that work
but it took a lot of imagination a lot
of creativity because
i will say this we never left the resort
um nobody left the resort once you were
there once we started shooting you
couldn't break that quarantine
and so the the dates you really had to
be creative our art department our
producers
you they really had to come up with some
amazingly creative ideas of how to
reimagine the same space over and over
um but they did so and what we really
learned was again at the end of the day
it is about the stories it's about the
romance
it's about claire going on this journey
these guys coming in
and again i'll credit to claire and
these guys to committing to this too
because they were kind of entering the
unknown um but it was a
very comfortable feel because
night one as the limos arrive and the
guys start arriving you felt okay
this this is going to be the back
tourette this does feel like the batch
right yeah it's a little different
but it was really important to us that
the show
looks like the bachelorette as much as
possible we're not in bora bora
we're not in italy but at the same time
we really wanted to feel like
you're watching the bachelorette you're
watching a love story we see claire
kissing this guy
in the promo and he's got a face mask on
it it's it's kind of a very fifty shades
of claire moment
um who is that if we're matching things
up it looks like it could be this guy
dale from his photo um hmm might be a
good guess
we'll see well if that is dale kissing
claire
what can you tell me about dale because
that's a sexy moment
we'll give you i'll give you a couple
guys to watch uh dale is among them
uh dale is someone a former football
player um i'll admit it stunningly
handsome
he's tall handsome the eyes dale dale
kind of has it all
and definitely he's someone who uh
immediately
captures uh claire's attention um
damar i will stick with the ds demar is
another guy uh
interesting title sport he's a spin
cycle instructor
um and maybe the best hype guy you'll
ever oh well great
in the promo we see claire really
shutting somebody down saying don't talk
to me like that she tells another person
you know that's not acceptable do we
have multiple bad boys this season
multiple bad i don't know what we call
bad voice let's say
yeah we'll say multiple bad boys um i'll
give you a couple to keep an eye on
uh joseph is definitely someone
who wears his heart on his sleeve is not
afraid to express
how he's feeling and it could be to
anybody including claire
um and so joseph is definitely someone
as far as drama goes you want to keep an
eye on
blake moynes who's 29 he's from he's
from canada
someone who's also going to be in the
thick of things and stir things up
i know you mentioned there are no rules
but there was some confusion because
seemingly when claire was still filming
her twitter account
liked and then unliked a tweet about
tasha then we get
photos of tasha on set with her phone
so do people have their phones on set
these days what's happening there
no uh i can i can for sure 100 tell you
that was not claire she did not have her
phone
i know this because i was with her and
then i know
the person that was with her uh and she
definitely didn't have her phone because
i know where her phone was
so i know i know it wasn't her for a
fact we've obviously seen tasha on set
so tasha is the bachelorette
what no claire
claire is the bachelorette so right now
you've not seen the promos
clearly you have not been watching the
promos could that
change next season it'll change
okay well answer me this tasha is
somebody who even after colton's season
there was discussion she could make a
great bachelorette what
would make tasha a great lead in all
seriousness
tasha's a very good friend of mine i
absolutely love and adore this woman
and i would love for her to have that
opportunity to be the bachelorette
should that ever arise um yeah she would
be a great candidate she always was and
she was on the top of our list from the
start
it would also mean another black lead
and potentially
back to back black bachelorette and then
a black bachelor which
would be great if she followed matt
james
is tasha not the bachelorette she's not
not the bachelorette
okay all right well you know what
i guess we're not gonna get the clarity
we're hoping for here today
just leave me with a tease for this
season the season
that blew up your show this is going to
be the most explosive season
you have ever seen you're guaranteeing
that that's how confident
this is 100 guaranteed
a season like any other i won't even say
it's the most dramatic
because that's not big enough
what is big enough blown up stephen
was blown up well let me ask you this
does claire get
a happy ending um
that remains to be seen what's your
reaction to claire's ending
um turbulent tumultuous
dramatic wild